it's a very mixed picture I mean he's
done some things that were very big very
important the stimulus package you got
passed in his first month in office it
was a it was important his big step
towards combating the downturn he's
gotten health care on the agenda he has
plans in his budget to start on health
care and he's worked with Congress to
have it include in the reconciliation
process which means the Republicans
can't filibuster it he's also put
forward ambitious plans and energy which
again that's part of the stimulus so
he's done a number of big important
things extended unemployment benefits
changing the formula so the lot of
people that had not been covered
previously are now covered and provided
health care benefits people are
unemployed will sixty-five percent of
their unemployment their health care
benefit covered by the government which
make affordable for a lot of people that
cannot otherwise Ford health insurance
once they lost their jobs so a lot of
good things we're giving bad marx's is
dealing with the financial system we had
a really big problem with finance run
amuck that's what got us here that's
what led to the downturn and it has to
be reined in and he doesn't seem
prepared at least he hasn't seen
prepared at this point to really take
the hard steps to rein in Wall Street
and what I worry is that we're going to
get out of this one costing the
taxpayers huge amounts of money because
we're looking at spending at least
hundreds of billions and quite possibly
over a trillion dollars in a bailout of
the banks and to basically leaving them
in shape leaving them as they were being
prepared to run amok again so I think it
would really be unfortunates a really
big drain to the taxpayers it's a huge
amount of money we've had big fights
over sums that were less than a
hundredth is large and then on top of
that not to not to wrestle back this
sector when it's really crying out for
serious regulation it really has to be
reined in Wall Street has to serve the
rest the economy when you have an
economy that's being run to serve the
financial sector you're asking for
trouble
you